Une citrouille, deux potirons,
trois courges, deux potimarrons.
La petite caméra m'a confié sa liste de courses...
Je devrais trouver tout ça ici,
je suis en Touraine au Château du Rivau.
Derrière ces murs, il y a 14  jardins dont un,
où ne poussent que des citrouilles et des potirons.
On y va ?
Ce château date du XVème siècle.
Rabelais qui est né dans le secteur,
nous sommes dans la région du Chinon, y
fait allusion dans son roman Gargantua.
Le géant du même nom, offre ce
château au capitaine Tolmer pour
le récompenser de sa victoire
lors des guerres picrocholines.
Pfff! Il y en a de toutes les
formes, de toutes les tailles,
de toutes les couleurs…
Je ne vais jamais m'y retrouver.
Tant pis, je rentre à l'atelier
pour éclaircir tout ça.
Citrouilles, potirons, c'est vrai qu'on
a un peu de mal à s'y retrouver.
Faut dire que ces deux-là appartiennent à la
même famille, une immense famille : les courges,
qui compte plus de 1000 variétés.
On y retrouve les courgettes,
les concombres, les cornichons, les pastèques,
les melons, les gourdes - qui ont donné leur
nom au récipient qui permet de transporter
de l'eau, étaient à l'origine des fruits.
Les potirons et les citrouilles également
qui appartiennent au genre - autrement dit
une branche de cette famille - Cucurbita.
Le problème c'est qu'en fonction de la région
où on se trouve, citrouilles et potirons
ne désignent pas toujours
le même cucurbita.
Alors comment s’y retrouver?
Je vous préviens, je ne vais pas régler le problème
d'un coup de baguette magique.
Au XIXème siècle, un botaniste français, Charles Naudin,
a réussi à mettre un peu d'ordre là-dedans.
En les observant de très près, il a remarqué certains détails
qui permettent de distinguerles citrouilles des potirons.
On retourne au Rivau ? Allez c'est parti !
Premier indice: l’aspect.
Les vraies citrouilles, (curcubita pépo),
ont une forme allongée
comme cette citrouille de Touraine.
Elle peut peser jusqu’à 18 kg.
En général, elle est cultivée pour l’alimentation
du bétail mais on peut aussi en faire des soupes et des confitures.
Les vrais potirons, eux, sont plus volumineux
plus ronds, plus dodus, ça se voit très bien sur
le rouge vif d'Etampes
ou sur le jaune grosde Paris.
Cucurbita pepo pour les citrouilles, cucurbita maxima pour les potirons.
C'est CharlesNaudin qui les a baptisés
et comme tous lesbotanistes,
les noms qu'il leur a donnés
ne sontpas anodins.
Deuxième indice, le pédoncule.
Il estdur avec des angles bien marqués et peut s'évaser
à la base de la citrouille alors que sur le
potiron, il est arrondi et ressemble à un bouchon de
liège, un peu spongieux.
Et maintenant, on va faire un petit test.
Voici un pâtisson.
Alors à votre avis,
citrouille ou potiron?
Bien que sa forme ne soit pas allongée,
c'est une citrouille,
ça se voitau niveau du pédoncule.
Il a des côtes bien marquées
et il s’évase à la base du fruit.
Et celui-ci?
Citrouille ou potiron?
Rassurez-vous, il n’est pas malade,
il pousse comme ça.
C’est un galeux d’Eysines et c’est un potiron
comme en témoigne sa forme,
bien ronde, bien dodue, et son pédoncule
spongieux comme un bouchon de liège.
Là où ça secomplique, c'est avec Cendrillon.
Maintenant quevous savez reconnaître une citrouille d'un potiron,
comment notre future princesse
est-elle allée au bal ? Retour au texte.
Dans la version originale du conte publié en 1697,
Charles Perrault raconteque la jeune femme part chercher la plus belle des
citrouilles de son jardin. Et il semble bien que ce
soit une citrouille, cucurbita pepo, que Gustave Doré,
lecélèbre illustrateur, représente dans les éditions
anciennes du XIXeme siècle.
Seulement voilà, au débutdu XXeme siècle, les illustrateurs
commencent àdessiner des cucurbitacées qui ressemblent
davantage à des potirons qu'à des citrouilles.
Et ledessin animé de Walt Disney en ajoute encore
une couche. Tandis que l'histoire parle toujours
de citrouille, c'est un potiron que la tante de
Cendrillon transforme en carrosse.
Il faut direqu'un potiron, ça peut être énorme.
Le plusgros du monde a été récolté en 2016 en Belgique,
il pesait 1200 kg, le poids d'une voiture ou d'uncarrosse.
D'où peut-être l'origine de la confusion.
Quoi qu'il en soit cet éclairage était nécessaire.
Tiens au fait, en parlant d'éclairage.
Pourquoi creuse-t-on des lanternes
dans les citrouilles au moment d'Halloween ?
Ah oui, je sais !
C'est unefête d'origine celte.
Ses racines se retrouvent
dans une ancienne fête irlandaise : Samhain.
J'espère que je prononce bien.
Célébrée le31 octobre et le 1er novembre.
Elle marque lafin de la saison des récoltes et le début de l'hiver.
A l'époque, on pensait que durant cette
période de l'année, la frontière entre le monde
des vivants et celui des morts était totalement
poreuse et que les esprits pouvaient communiqueravec les Hommes.
C'était l'occasion d'allumer des
grands feux, de jouer des tours en se déguisant
en morts-vivants et de creuser des lanternes non pas
dans des citrouilles mais dans... Je vous montrer.
Dans un navet. Au milieu du XIXeme siècle, la grande
famine pousse des millions d'irlandais à quitter
leur pays pour les Etats-Unis.
Ils emmènent leur culture et leurs traditions
seulement, le navet nepousse
pas très bien en Amérique du Nord.
Pour la fête d’Halloween, il est
remplacé par des citrouilles qui,
j'avais oublié de vous le préciser,
sont originaires du Nouveau Monde.
Ce sont lesConquistadors qui les ont rapportées
en Europeau début du XVIeme siècle.
La citrouille remplace doncle navet
pour la fête d'Halloween, elle en devientmême le symbole.
En particulier la Jack-o-lantern.
Celle-ci. Elle tient son nom d'une ancienne légende
irlandaise, Jack à la lanterne,
condamnépar le Diable à errer pour l'éternité
dans l'obscurité en tenant à la main
une lanterne creusée dans navet...
devenu une citrouille.
Ça va? Vous me suivez?
Moi j’ai la tête comme une citrouille!
Et en plus, je n'ai pas encore fait les courses
pour la petite caméra.
Allez, j'y vais.
A bientôt.
Le moment est maintenant
venu de répondre
à vos questions. Depuis le début de cette
aventure vous êtes très nombreux à m'interroger
sur les différents sujets que je traite dans mes
vidéos. Aujourd'hui, je vais donc répondre à quelques
questions sur la moutarde. Revox me demande si la
moutarde présente des risques pour la santé ou si
elle possède des vertus. Eh bien d'après de nombreux
diététiciens, la moutarde contient beaucoup de
vitamine C, on y trouve également de la vitamine
B2 B6 et B9 ainsi que du magnésium et du calcium.
Rien que des nutriments qui apportent de l'énergie à
l'organisme. Bon, vous n'êtes pas non plus obligé
d'en avaler 3 cuillérées au petit-déjeuner. Une
question moins drôle mais qui revient souvent :
quelrapport entre la moutarde et le sinistre gaz du
même nom utilisé comme arme chimique pendant la
Première Guerre mondiale notamment ? Eh bien aucun
rapport. Si ce gaz a été baptisé gaz moutarde,
c'esttout simplement parce que son odeur, dans certaines
conditions, rappelle celle de la moutarde.
Enfin, quelle différence entre la moutarde fine et la
moutarde à l'ancienne ? Eh bien ces deux moutardes
sont fabriquées à partir des mêmes graines qui
sont broyées. À ce stade, on obtient de la moutarde
à l'ancienne, une moutarde qui contient des graines
et aussi le tégument des graines, autrement dit, leurenveloppe.
Pour obtenir de la moutarde fine, eh bien
il faut passer cette pâte dans une centrifugeuse, un cylindre
qui tourne très vite, qui va permettre
de séparer la sauce des graines.
Voilà, il ne me reste plus qu'à vous souhaiter
une bonne dégustation. Atrès bientôt.
Et je vous le promet, on va continuer à se régaler.
Citrons, potirouilles... Potirouilles...
Les illustrateurs commencent à dessiner
des krukru... Hop.
des cu...  Des cur... Des cucurbitacées ! Je bois.